what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here John Humphrey here we finally got a
trailer I'm assuming from New York
comic-con from cific rim uprising
eggsy's back looking to be great talk
that jokes better than I was gonna make
but just a little heads up shout out
today Ferengi Terpening Terps
[Music]
destruction is back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and the monsters we created to stop them
we thought we had sacrificed enough
we thought we finished the only thing
standing in front of the apocalypse
[Music]
is us
[Music]
doesn't matter where you came from
[Music]
this is our time this is our chance to
make a difference
[Music]
very sweet
[Music]
our school
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
everything you
[Music]
[Music]
slightly teary-eyed this time we will
fight in the middle of a city instead of
in the sea fought in the city last time
there's that one giant fighting in the
sea like off the coast
this looks like the you know the better
version of transformers which is what I
think I said the first time I saw it
first trailer for Pacific at one point
just show John boyega he's turning he's
dodging a rocket that's coming at him I
remember hearing us I think there's just
a speculation idea that gear of those
four avenues originally attached which
was that he would have like this half
kaiju half Jaeger monster because of
what happens in the first one when they
go to like destroy the core part the
Jaeger drops in there and and so maybe
they have like technology that they were
able to grab so they could form a Jaeger
cheesy like you know I'll have to see
how the movie treats that one if there's
like a baby kaiju Yeager hybrid thing
that just doesn't make any sense to me
so I handled I imagine the Kai's you
created the Jaeger and so they don't
have like thumbs or you know discernible
brain who cares man it's cool this kaiju
had sex with a Jaeger and now we've got
a baby Jaeger kaiju I'm gonna be like
hang on a second can I check your
physics wouldn't be cool it just gotta
have a good reason to do it I'm shy I
think I've already bought it without
them having to explain it's like I like
the first position I love at least I
like John boyega a lot I mean Hollywood
really wants me to love Scott Eastwood
and maybe this time role of Scott
Eastwood a couple differences I noticed
is I don't know if this is because I
never actually saw Pacific or in part
one in a 2d format
I saw it three times and
max 3d okay I really enjoyed it so I'm
looking at the cinematography here it
looks a lot brighter in terms like more
colorful yeah almost like a comic book
so I'm wondering if in this time around
and they've lighted up the overall tone
just a bit because I saw three times the
first one and I remember thinking like
it takes itself a little too seriously
it's I feel like this could work better
if it was a little more cheesy or a
little bit more light that's why I
thought Charlie day and the other guy
Gorman his character felt a little out
of place in the first one even though I
enjoy them they're funnier than the rest
yeah cuz I was like the rest of the tone
is very serious and even this is serious
like trailer in terms of like you know
that's music and this style is dogged
yeah I come across that epic tone well
I'm jumping is performance in this
trailer at least the parts they show you
that definitely like he's going for it
yeah it's serious again but because of
the way it's shot it feels like it's
just gonna feel a little bit lighter and
it's in its appeal in its town which is
a cool thing to think about I just hope
it doesn't become transformers that's
all because it could easily become
transformers because the humans are
inside of the machines and then the
movie takes time it's the first one did
to be emotionally invested within the
humans that are inside of the machine
and that's why I think it's better are
they independent staying to this where
John boyega is Idris Elba's son oh yeah
you know he's a stacker Pentecost did
not like that okay and everything about
his thing here like looks like it - I
was like oh yeah he's got a father's
motivational speech yeah whatever he
says we're canceling the apocalypse yeah
okay it's not as frustrating because of
the events that happened in the Pacific
or one because I'm in an independent
state - it's like they couldn't get Will
Smith back so they just killed him off
the biggest difference that I think I'll
really feel with this film - is you know
everyone thought a dress elbow was the
best one out of Pacific Rim but he
wasn't the main character he was one of
the main supporting characters but it
was Charlie Hunnam who was the main
character this one seems to really be
advertising that job leg is gonna be the
main character yeah for sure
I highly doubt I will not be invested in
whatever job yeah he always compels me
in in everything else yeah returning to
big sci-fi again I I still find him
pretty compelling and at the end of the
day this movie I just never I didn't
think I saw it three times and I never
thought it was as deep as like people
were kind of hoping it could kind of be
I don't know about the work deep deep I
mean like it has its heart in a better
place than a lot of yeah more action
sci-fi extravagances at the end of the
day it's just a really fun well made
machines versus monsters movie but yeah
like it at the end of the day that that
is what it is yeah I know and that is it
knows it to a certain degree
yeah the the effects look great still
the action still looks great the thing
though was the first one I thought was
dark was lit a little darker because
oftentimes when you when you like
something darker it can make things like
these big spectacles and machines and
monsters look more realistic because
that's why I saw it so many times
because I was so impressed by the
visuals and I'm wondering that with the
brightly colored palette like the fact
that they have like daylight fighting
scenes will it look more fake yeah
that's what I'm wondering about while
I'm watching this because half my brain
wants to go oh cool like even more crazy
Jaeger kaiju action they've even changed
some of the designs the kaiju like this
looks so cool and the other half of my
brain is like is this gonna devolve into
you know just a lot of loud noises and
buildings yeah I'm bling and you
is it gonna basically undo the goodwill
that the first film built for me in a
landscape full of movies just like this
I don't know it looks it looks like it's
gonna be very entertaining to me yeah
which I picture well the biggest
difference I noticed in their marketing
here is like no one walked away from
pursuit of girl going like Charlie
Hunnam you know yeah but this one looks
like oh well I'm gonna be invested in
something I would like to be for a new
Pacific Rim and maybe that'll make this
one you know more successful because she
wrote a page for the day shout-out for
Angie Terpening mr. Terpening my good
friend who reads a lot of books served
in the military he came on this channel
before actually oh yeah you know at one
time he visited California I think that
if there's one person John and I could
share one side of a Jaeger with
interpreting on the other side and
you're Terpening you'd be the one we
core with and I would follow you in the
battle I think between the three of us
if one of us was to take charge of a
situation oh you would know considering
the fact that you're the only one right
between three of us as military
experience we trust you to fight
monsters love you and you're you're such
a sweet man with a beautiful singing
voice all right guys what do you think
of Pacific Rim uprising are you worried
about it do you expect this to be more
impactful and meaningful that what it
actually is or does it look like just a
really much better version of
transformers meets the Power Rangers
well guys you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
follow dat John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram and check out our patreon
become a patreon eject today join us